oh there it is his Hannibal Burres
listen to the handsome Rambler episode 2
I'm here with Tony trim hey guys so neat
trim we're sitting in Portland Oregon in
a house in an Airbnb house a nice house
in the northwest neighborhood of
Portland Oregon it's a good house five
bedrooms it looks good I like it I'm
inspired I hope we don't mess it up
sometimes I get bad air B&B reviews when
it's a group of us in the house and we
have elaborate cookouts in Opa in Omaha
the guy in Omaha was really upset with
us he was so mad to be fit we did have a
party when we we invited people over and
then word got around and it was a bunch
of random dudes two showed up at the
house and we had to tell them to leave
but and so apparently these people were
hanging out in the neighbor's lawns and
I didn't know about that you know about
that yeah so people went to the wrong
house so they was just chilling in
people's yards at 2:00 3:00 in the
morning why would you do that that's so
stupid and I don't even know any of
these people we may be told three girls
that we had the party at our house and
then 30 people showed up and it wasn't a
good time
or uh or you remember like in
Minneapolis when when we had that import
that improvised house party that was
weird as hell oh well yeah in in in in
Minneapolis right before I filmed comedy
kamisato or when I film comedy , Sodom
actually we had a after-party our old
buddy
rapper long shot we said hey we're gonna
throw a little house party just you know
let a couple people know and we come
from the club and there is 20 people 20
30 people just waiting on the porch I
guess there's some the Minneapolis late
night party crew
cuz everybody left at once also but they
were all it was weird because it was
like a big ask who they were all friends
with yeah they all knew each other
South taken up it was a weird dynamic
just 30 but he had a good time but it's
just you know nobody stole anything
that's cool I think some stuff got
broken the hosts were they were very
they weren't upset but you know we did
check out a little late it was a bit of
a mess got started some extra fees on
that you hope nobody listens to this and
then when I don't I don't I don't I
don't everybody out of my real name
anymore
I switched it up cuz I don't want to get
publicly scolded so this Omaha guys oh
you were a bad guest and it was messy it
wasn't that bad the hardwood floors were
scratched
what were you do it on the floors we
will walk it on the floor see act like
we were ice skating on that [ __ ] or
something it was just regular wear and
tear on people walking on the floors we
didn't have a tap dancing competition
we weren't cutting cucumbers on the
floors it was just shoes on the floor I
don't know what type of finish maybe you
need to talk with your contractor about
the type of flooring you use it anyways
he was I think he could tell cuz he you
could he was saying that that was his
first home and he was like fixing it up
I think more that he was just he's not
meant for that Airbnb game he's really
also he's too connected to it yeah
that's what I mean today lit so they
lived there yeah I wonder where they
went yeah I wouldn't want to area that's
the thing if I was I want to I don't
know if I want to Airbnb
where I actually
it was too personal because remember he
had pictures of his whole family
everywhere in the cribs yeah he lives
there and looks at pictures of his
family members yeah and so that's weird
for guests to look at because you don't
know these people I don't know if it's
weird to look it's just I feel like he
just get really he just saw in his his
email he'd sent a private review to me
it was very nice if I could pull this up
man because uh he was very upset he was
just super exist oh man it wasn't that
bad at all it was just a little bit
messy but if you read his message
without seeing what the reality was then
you would think that uh you think I
totally destroyed no and like me and me
and Marcus have made it a point to like
really clean it up before he left that
all the dishes everything swept it up so
it wasn't like we did a cookout and just
left [ __ ] everywhere and I skated on the
floor like you said yeah let me see man
let me see
Hannibal you broke many house rules
during your stay not only did you damage
my wood floors again I don't how do we
damage the floors but you left the house
in total disarray which needed extensive
cleaning false additionally you upset my
neighbors who out of respect for me
didn't call the police
if they would have called the police
didn't like the police want to show them
that hell it's loud really all right
Hannibal you party and he keeps on
saying my name I don't like how much
he's says my name is Hannibal you party
late into every morning keeping the
neighbors on both sides up
we didn't party the first night I think
maybe y'all did I kept a chill you had
guests who showed up at the wrong house
a few doors to hell and partied in their
backyard I haven't got what does that
have to do I don't know I didn't know
any of these people they departed in the
backyard that's all new you can't blame
that on me but that's such odd behavior
like I've never
I heard of that happening like you go to
a house party and you're like [ __ ] it
let's go to this random backyard and
party yeah who does that who just says
it's hanging at a yard that's some weird
Omaha Nebraska [ __ ] it's very strange
loitering you were incredibly
disrespectful of our first house roll
please be in by 9:00 p.m. and keep noise
to a minimum I was in by night what
Hannibal he keeps on saying my name
Hannibal you admitted to smoking on the
patio I didn't smoke on the patio why
can't we smoke on the patios outside
my neighbor said you kept the door wide
open my home smelled like smoke upon
your departure Hannibal you admitted to
having more than the three people that
you put on a reservation you said that
there were only two more but but my
neighbors said that there were on the
upwards of 20 or more people coming to
the house each night that's completely
false twenty people each night
Thundercat was on these are little
Thundercat and I forget his keyboard is
his then they came through and a couple
people came to say the last night it was
a bunch of people but that was out of my
control they wasn't twenty [ __ ]
people coming into the house each night
that would drive me crazy my kitchen and
dining room got the brunt of the damages
my newly installed bamboo wood floors
were scratched in no less than ten
places that's just people walking on the
floors that's what happens I'm sorry we
didn't take our shoes off deep scratches
we've had to have the planks replaced
the floors were so coated in booze food
and outside debris that my flip-flops
stuck to the floor in certain areas
hey how about you get better flip-flops
or start wearing shoes additional wood
floor planks had to be replaced as hard
alcohol effectively removed the fitness
food was stuck to the dining table it
was much scrubbing luckily it didn't
have permanent damage I was able to get
out the big liquor rings as well the
patio grill was covered in grease is a
grill the patio table and chairs were
like
I was covered in grease and barbecue
sauce I had to have them scrubbed down
and Power Wash food wrappers and food
were left on the patio and much I've
blown into the fizz next door damp
towels were everywhere what do you damp
towels were everywhere some hung up in
ether home but others would damp laying
on the carpet the bathroom upstairs was
covered in to the pace beer bottles beer
bearded shaving and more it wasn't
covered in beer bottles I can't
it was one beer bottom but we drank a
beer in the room and then put that beer
bottle in the garbage can in the
bathroom it just wasn't a bathtub full
of beer bars aside from the terrible way
that you and your guests left the home
you would not even give me the
opportunity to talk about these issues
you said you should not have to deal
with this as you paid too much money to
stay here Sully didn't go sit in your
car as I did the walkthrough yeah I'm
not gonna sit I don't walk around with
you through the house that was odd
because wait what did you say like is at
one point you're just like just charge
me for whatever so we can get the hell
out it around like you're my principal
and walk around the house would you so
he had if you wanted to burry yeah yes
oh yeah he had my car blocked in in the
so I was like dude I'm about to [ __ ]
do this what you meant yeah you do you
do you can go look at that [ __ ] I'm not
walking around with you like a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he's straight he straight wanted to
point at everything and berate you for
it and it was it wasn't in that bad a
shape so yeah you can go do that i'ma
sit in this car
I don't know who the [ __ ] you think I am
but you can go walk around the house and
point at stuff and then you just send me
an e-mail I'll deal with it from now huh
I thought you wouldn't yet you said if
you shouldn't have the duties paid too
much money it's only go sit in your cars
I did the walkthrough yet sorry to say
Hannibal but you didn't treat me my
house on my neighbor's well I put my
blood sweat and tears into this
renovation my house that I love I go out
of my way to make sure the house is in
perfect condition for you to guess
breaking my house rules damaging my home
keeping up my neighbors and total
disrespectful attitude
for the entire situation was not
acceptable Steve he was filling a
stipple way he was very upset this is
what happens when you rent out your
personal home to strangers and I know
people I know some people will be
doesn't want to take Steve sack you're
wrong you're wrong you're wrong
if your air being being like it was a
slight it was a it was a slight mess but
you're in the hospitality business right
hospitality business he's exaggerating
it a bit
that [ __ ] was a light not as I've been a
lot of bit it's a it's a to what he's
talking about
really maybe a two three-hour clean
honey some dollars
I got a Polish lady back home that
cleaning for six just the fact that he's
talking about it uh it be the bathroom
being covered in beer by it beard
shavings toothpaste you mean like a
bathroom who washes a bathroom after
they leave a place it's - oh there's
toothpaste on the back in the back don't
sink oh [ __ ]
these guys are heathens but where was it
was it was that in Nashville where
they're like there's a weird brown
substance on the table yeah oh right
like some hair like hair and Steve Steve
if you somehow listen and Steve in Omaha
I got my dick sucked twice at your house
[Laughter]
yes okay okay the other one was in East
Nashville yeah
nice house cool Liston and so we stayed
we stayed two nights because we had
Zaidi's gig and middle tea Middle
Tennessee State University in
Murfreesboro her first Murfreesboro
Tennessee and and so we kicked it there
a little bit we had we had some girls
ever smoked a little weed that was it
the place was pretty in good st. beyond
that I think somebody left a roach out
of something in us maybe somebody left
the road since I saw somebody put the
road shot in a bottle cap somebody put
the roach out in a bottle cap in a beer
bottle cap of something like that yeah
and that was it besides that the place
was clean we left it in good shape and
so this lady who also she lived in the
house directly next door so she owned
these two houses next door to each other
how about you put that on the list know
if I'm renting a place let me know that
you stay next door because I might not
want to live next to you I might just
let me know and it was weird because
they were hanging out on the porches
always on that porch she's just like hey
how's it going on me just regretting
this transaction [ __ ] out of here and so
zero I cannot in good conscience give
you a positive review you left remnants
of illegal drugs throughout the house
net throughout the house there was one
roach in that bottle cap remnants of
illegal drugs get out here you hypocrite
how about this she when we got there she
welcomed us with a bottle of wine but
she illegal drugs no marijuana
hey woman
hey guess what is legal in some places
you left remnants of illegal drugs stop
talking like the places just weave just
sprinkle in PCP there's like needles
there's needles everywhere shut up it
was one Roach get out of here
what'd you do for recreation is your
business but it was lack of respect and
stupidity to smoke in our house and
leave your roaches on the kitchen spoon
it's not stupid it's fine
it wasn't lack of respect just one to
smoke weed at night and hang out I don't
even know if I smoked that's I I think I
was just chilling but it's not stupidity
shut up shut up you're in the hotel
business
somebody might smoke weed we left it out
so be it leave your brothers or the
kitchen along with some sort of dark
brown sticky substance also found in the
master bedrooms now this is what this
one bought that line bother me this
brown sticky stuff because that was this
uh the sticky substance you talk about
it's um it was a facial scrub that I was
using at the time you know sometimes I
like to I like to take care of my skin
and use some you know sometimes I get
expensive skin products to exfoliate
with but it sounds like she's alluding
to the fact that I might have been doing
a heroin honestly I'll be I'll be honest
with you because you had forward me that
email and I was like reading it and when
I read this sticky brown substance I
thought she thought that like you had
[ __ ] on the floor some dark brown sticky
substance what does she take it she
thought it was heroin really what was a
[ __ ] she's that fall you know my husband
could be working for the DEA what what
do you what who what DEA agent is also
written out property of every
be hey [ __ ] you and your husband and the
DEA my vice is it next time you stay in
an air B&B that you cover your tracks
better out of simple respect so she said
eh you could do that [ __ ] I just don't
want to see it hey you sound stupid this
year oh thank you
I lit her ass up you want to know what I
wrote back we might I I kind of I kind
of win hard sometimes I can go here's
what I wrote back I said newsflash
people have done and will continue to do
way worse things to smoke joints in your
tacky house your issue seems to be about
to clean up but that's why clean and
flee is included you're a hypocrite
because the first thing you did was
offer us a bottle of wine alcohol is
cool but weed is it get the [ __ ] out of
here
or whatever your real name is thanks for
the unsolicited advice you judgmental
idiot [ __ ] whatever you make it whatever
you make it a year written out that dump
I'm making an hour telling jokes to
college students I'll be fighting what
if your husband was a DEA agent I don't
know if he was a DEA agent he probably
wouldn't be spending his time cleaning
the sink before 3 p.m. so some source
from Kansas become overpay for a shack
and [ __ ] any for a weekend in between
trips to honky tonks idiot the brown
substance was a facial scrub by the way
you goofy busybody
[Laughter]
okay I see you're trying to get a little
creative there yeah yeah and I said grow
the [ __ ] up it'll be legal everywhere so
that's a very good response it's a bit
harsh it's a bit harsh but it was you
know I give you credit because it wasn't
just hey [ __ ] you you stupid [ __ ] it's
like you got creative with it yeah
that's some good wordplay and there was
some good there were some good moments
than that yeah that response yeah all
right what is that yeah all right well
we're gonna talk about what I got going
on Airbnb wise after these messages
yeah it's time to talk for money add
time check out Cecil s E as oh the new
ad free streaming service bringing you
hilarious original series hand-picked
classics weeks of stand-up specials and
more yeah ad free no ads for deodorant
or anything or cars that you are never
bad you don't have to watch you just
watch the stuff you want to watch the
next big names in comedy and the
established comedian like louis c.k
chelsea peretti Amy Schumer Bo Burnham
and so many more see so is at free you
hear me
at free and it's just 399 per month
three dollars in 99 cents per month
that's less than an expensive juice
that's less than a naked juice that's
less than most beer get into it see so
yes so what's what's what's new with the
spot the building uh so yeah I got this
build it in in Chicago the when I got it
I bought it in July and there were
tenants in it and so I wanted to I
wanted to put the the units on Airbnb
and
so I asked all the tenants to leave I
offered them two months free rent I
never took any rent from them as you
know hopefully incentive for them to
want to move without much trouble so now
I'm I'm still learning with real estate
and getting more organized because for
some one of the leases was up in the end
of May 2017 the other leases were up
this September and this August I mean I
don't have to give them free rent I
could have taken the rent and just not
renew the lease so that's some money
down the drain
but everybody agreed to leave by the end
of September so it was cool but then
there was a one Senate that asked me
could he stay two weeks more no be about
to start doing work on a unis and then I
said I gave him an extra couple days and
then I had I got somebody you know
buying the furniture and doing the
design and painting for me and so she
she had to say while I'm out of town and
so she sent she sends me pictures of the
place and the dude and left you couldn't
even really you weren't even sure if the
dude moved out they left a treadmill in
that [ __ ] they left it was the
refrigerator was full some bunch of
stuff in the room and I wrote him I said
dude that's how you gonna leave the
place he says sorry uh you know I didn't
have time to clean it out you should
have been operating as if you're gonna
be moving out when we agreed to go move
out you should have been operating as if
you're gonna get the two weeks extra my
bad man I just wrote back [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
going back and forth roasting my former
tenant he's a dirtbag it's a real
dirtbag anyways all three units are
clear and so when I was back in Chicago
last week I went in checked out the spot
and just you know and it's it's kind of
crazy the first thing I've owned that
substantial outside of shirts in the
xbox and you know a couple pieces of
furniture and it was nice just to stand
on my porch this is my goddamn porch I
almost wanted a good I just felt like I
wanted a gun standing on my on my porch
it's just that's the feeling that you
had from owning a home like I have yeah
protect this property you gonna run up
on my porch run up on this board come up
in you don't want no trouble don't come
past that game try to tell me oh you
know what one time actually the my
landlord was like fixing some stuff
where I live right next to a soccer
field and he came by fix him some stuff
and the ball flew over the fence yeah
and then the kids are like can we get
the ball he's like no I'm taking this
ball yeah like come on and he's like if
you try to hop this fence he's like I
have the legal right to shoot you know
he was not getting mad Oh cuz he cuz
there's balls flying over all the time
[ __ ] up his property like messing up
the whole porch beams were getting hit
like this so he says are getting tired
of he's tired of it but I never said
that kids I'll [ __ ] with the kids
sometimes like if it comes from over
again I'm taking it whatever this [ __ ]
goes up on onto the porch while we're
grilling or whatever you know yeah not
safe but when it happened with him he
was
he's like no I'm taking this ball and if
you try to come and get it I'm gonna
shoot you what type of what type of dude
is your landlord he was well actually
wasn't my landlord it was the management
company and he's gotten a lot of
complaints about it so like he's just
like I think he's like Romanian yeah he
just had like he just had that like
don't [ __ ] with me Eastern European real
like strong kind of vibe to him and yeah
it was like I will shoot it to a kid to
like a think the kid was like 15 16 but
he I mean he probably just wanted to say
something strong
yeah well that's exactly what I mean he
I don't think he had a gun on him it
just I think he was just like you know I
like I don't take no [ __ ] I need to say
something yes show people that I'm that
plan wait and he just kept the ball yeah
and he just kept Lee you took the ball
putting this truck and drove off anyways
so yeah I understand your gun your gun
thing detectives builded so we're
getting it hopefully I'll have it up on
Airbnb in the next few weeks
got somebody buying a furniture and all
that stuff I'm traveling but it's
decisions that I have to make about
things that cuz we're getting the floors
redone so the floors a little you know I
have a question for you what so since
you are air B&B that it is like it is a
business you're gonna somehow try to put
it out there as this is Hannibal Burres
is air B&B or you just try to keep that
on the low I that's the conflict and
that's something I've been thinking
about yeah is do I want the that's the
thing do I want I mean once it's all set
up and everything yeah I really won't
need to ever be at it or see I mean I
can I'll have people check up on it or
whatever but I don't need to be present
at the building or whatever working
worried about my saying but I wonder if
somebody will just want to rent it and
[ __ ] it up because it's mine yeah that's
nice
or like would that be able to help with
it I'll be able to get the press I think
Airbnb has insurance and the other the
other types of websites that I think
there's one VRBO that have insurance for
that type of thing and also I the
difference between me and and Steve is
that I've known I'm head on living
exactly
I won't live in this part and I'm
already prepared I'm now gonna have like
really be emotionally connected to it's
gonna be a business I have stuff in
there I'm are I'm already anticipating
something getting broken maybe some get
stolen yeah and it's part of the game
and you I mean it happens at hotels to
incidentals incidental sometimes
incidents might happen and that's why
you get incidentals and so that's what
I'm prepared to deal with that and you
know just seeing Steve I don't I don't
plan on writing long Airbnb reviews sand
people's first names over and over to
them if they would clean it clean if
they were dirty you did that dirty and
then we move all clean us [ __ ] up and
get the next body up in there and get
that dealt they [ __ ] it up you charge
them in charge them get out of my blood
sweat cleaning lady shut your ass up and
go spend time with your family while you
stand in long ass emails and the floors
and the bathroom was full of toothpaste
yeah
get a life see it was exciting yeah is
really it's something because it's
something so different
stand-up entertainment stuff is fun for
me
still but it's like you know is I it's a
job I'm excited to have it appreciative
appreciative of but it's not you know
that having the built is out of my
comfort zone where they the decision
that stuff about what color should the
floor be or what quotes getting quotes
on floors I don't know how much floors
are supposed to cost
I'll just get a few quotes and is if
they seem
they right around the same price tonight
I guess I'm not getting [ __ ] over
unless all of them are in a union all
the flooring business are in a union
would they come together and make sure
the high ball everybody within a five
hundred dollar range got you
what if that's the conspiracy any
contractors I'll tell you what though
any Chicago area contractors hit me up
at the handsome Rambler at gmail.com and
I need to before you're some advice but
but before you said that I was about to
say I got some guys that'll do it for
real cheap sand polish guys really
yeah real cheap like they're I mean
they'll give you like the high ball
price and they'll give you like the low
price but you might be kind of having
cutting corners but I got some guys are
really good with that kind of stuff why
are you just now telling me this because
we're talking about it I would I see you
they almost every day you never told me
you're looking for a deal I thought
you're just getting [ __ ] done
I'm always looking for a deal I'm
constantly looking for a deal that is K
so much okay I'm constantly looking for
something the cheapness I thought you
had a guy I don't have a guy just we
well I got a guy spots see now I got it
I think we got it I think they might be
doing that they starts a day they might
have started on the floors today next
time other stuff like lighting fixtures
or whatever I got a guy I need to know
that guy he's good
I need the deals I need a deal I'm all
about the deal you'll hook it up on the
strength of just you know being a fan of
your system yeah yeah he's a fan he's a
fan and he do work like lights and stuff
he does all that [ __ ] see man hell yeah
and yeah yeah there's a strong community
in Chicago that's on some like non-union
independent contract and work and if
your homies you just get in real good
you know I need that I need this stuff
is adding up man yeah expense it's a
furnace place I can imagine furnace in
three places paint walls floors
carpeting stuff here's the thing with
carpet yeah in the bedrooms putting
carpet in the bedroom most of that
carpet is not even really being used
yeah a huge amount of the square footage
don't do carpet cuz it's gonna get like
jizz all in it and all kinds of weird
stuff it's gonna get so gross just go
hardwood yeah yeah
carpet is because you got a steam clean
it and you got people you got their
fluids all getting soaked inside of it
you don't wanna do that [ __ ] getting
spilled man now you tell them your
hardwood floors that everybody knows
that as they that's the best the easiest
maintenance tiles in the bathroom and
hardwood floors throughout the house
just like this crib ain't no carpet in
here oh man I got a text
if your air B&B you get carpet is for
like if you got kids and [ __ ] and they
want to hang out in the den you don't
want to bump their heads around on the
floor oh man this is this is I got a
text turn now I think oh man man no
carpet man living you learn we'll see
clean that stuff up we keep it fresh we
keep it fresh staying guard is the best
yo carpet companies then I put them to
the test
age beat got a Superman tatted on my
chest and my chest hair is the best hit
all right Tony
you kind of really upset me man why did
I've sent you cuz not upset with this
information I wish you would have talked
you never asked me for advice on any of
this stuff you just you just keep keep
saying yeah I got this crib the only
advice you asked me was like got this
guy he's being a dick or he's not moving
what do I do about these tenants and I
gave you my advice on that I said yeah
yeah give him the extra month be cool
whatever but right you never asked me
about floors and carpet and she'll like
that
no I don't know why you didn't ask just
didn't I don't know I guess is this you
know I got connections
yeah well we got him Carville is is on
the next building you know yeah once
this one get set
the next builder I'm trying to get out
of the game in seven years
gotcha I'm trying to get out of the
comedy game when it when I'm 40 and do
dis buildings and come up with an app
app where strangers no strangers
high-five each other I don't know how
are you say you want a diet yeah I'm I'm
trying to stay because we're on the road
so heavy exercise is not as easy
sometimes exercise not easy because I
get hungover or tired or just kind of or
we're doing some work or it's like
soundcheck is usually really early so
I'm just kind of don't have the
motivation so I feel like I got to eat
differently I got a burn fat without
frying I guess oh yeah yeah
the rock always finds time to work out
but I'm not the rock kevin hart always
finds time to work out yeah but Kevin
Hart is rich and doesn't need to sound
check at 5:00 p.m. and what about right
in between sound Tech and she'll get
that seven-minute workout here and then
push ups and crunches that's what he
lunges that's what I drink
sounds like I mean the diet is
interesting I had some questions about
it
it sounds like your bad time manager man
yeah maybe that is a little bit to do
with it
you sound like horrible time management
you drink an imbecile right out the
soundcheck instead of working out well I
don't get like smashed I just like to
get a little loose but this pencast I
mean also this you know just say you
know I get a little bit more personal
when I have a couple of drinks right so
I figure you know I want to give the
crowd right that's also drunk during the
show you know it's not like I'm house
during the show yeah I mean you know
what happened what happened with the 2
Chainz
technology with the to say is cute
technology is not as easy to work with
within the live setting like that yeah
it might seem like just pushing buttons
but [ __ ] gets [ __ ] up easily regularly
and it's almost like miraculous how
smooth this shit's been going without
any mistakes that's good man
thanks yeah especially with the video
[ __ ] man every time I get up there and I
hit the video stuff I get super nervous
cuz I know
my laptop isn't quite there yet to
handle that kind of pressure but somehow
she's being a champ and handling it okay
and he wants to diet so the diet it's
the key it's the ketosis diet the
ketosis diet the keto diet for short cut
ptosis how do you spell ketosis k ET OS
is ketosis and it's a you know joe rogan
always talks about it yeah it's
basically when you're you're you're
you're cutting your carb and sugar
intake and then so your body starts when
you keep like your carbs and sugar under
about like 50 to 30 grams a day your
body starts producing ketones mmm and
what happens from there is it's your
body starts burning your fat reserves
yeah so you just start rapidly rapidly
losing weight so that means basically I
cut out like desserts and candy and
bread grains so my meals just kind of
consists of like meat cheeses and
vegetables wait
but ketosis is saying I'm looking at it
it's a it's a state of the body yeah but
it can be ketosis can be bad sometime
yeah I think it for like diabetics it's
not good for them because it messes with
their insulin levels yeah yeah okay cuz
it says symptoms develop quickly they
may include excessive thirst yeah
frequent urination nausea belly pain
fatigue shortness of breath
fruity senate breath what
I want that fruit easy to breath that I
never saw
I never see that as a symptom of
something fruity oh you got fruity SATA
breath your breath smell like pine and
you press to my light yeah a man you
smell like blueberries you about to die
what are you doing so you've been so
it's been even you you've been feeling
good doing it yeah actually you know
what the best thing about it is is that
when you when you consume that much fat
and protein you your hunger goes away
which is great for the road so it's like
I don't have to constantly like eat so
if I'm like trying to get this
soundcheck get some [ __ ] set up usually
I'm like oh now I gotta find something
to eat before the show otherwise I'm not
eating for like three hours and I freak
out because then and I end up not eating
for like eight hours which is terrible
for you but then now I can just kind of
pull out a bag of beef jerky eat some
nuts real fast and I'm good for like a
bunch of hours you know so it's great
for the road because you're yeah like it
significantly makes my hunger it
controls my hunger and it's I'm I'm down
with it it's great and I feel good you
can't eat oranges no too much sugar I
can't eat a lot of fruits except for
like maybe a minimal amount of berries
you can't eat grapes no grapes but I can
drink wine
why because wine doesn't have that many
well per glass it's about like through
it like 3 grams 3 grams of carbs so as
long as I keep it to like three or four
glasses I'm okay do you get more drunk
now no no I don't ketosis not at all it
doesn't affect my buddies at all but one
thing I do miss is like drinking crappy
beer cuz I really do miss a good good
just shitty Pilsner yeah yeah alright
I'm looking at this and yeah a lot of
people were inspired by Rogan so check
it out yeah they say once you get over
the sugar addiction yeah and I don't
even crave carbs anymore I don't like
look at bread
like oh I need bread like it's weird
like once you figure out how to cut that
out completely because I I sped up my
process by fasting for a day I just
drank water didn't heat I was just like
it was one of the hardest things I've
ever had to do cuz if anybody knows me
they know I like to eat and I'm hungry
as dude yeah you've been you wanted a
hungers people I know oh I say you top
ten hungry is dead or alive so for me to
do that there's a lot so yeah I got
through it and then the next day or two
I can feel my body going into ketosis
cuz I can I can start getting this weird
metallic taste in my mouth
and I was feeling like a little
light-headed and weird I could tell
something was happening and then sure
enough like well it's been like ten days
now yeah I could I can feel I could see
myself slimming down and definitely feel
better so and I get to eat all this [ __ ]
I really like to eat yeah you know I can
still eat a charcuterie plate nice like
we did today that was delicious
alright I uh I stopped drinking for a
week I didn't know how long I was gonna
last
it was really tough yeah that's always
tough tables huh yeah I did it
especially on the road on a road is
really tough yeah like at the crib
lighting just not drinking it you you
know is I found myself just leaving
places and not being able to be around
people that much if I wasn't smoking you
just show that kind of just chill at the
crib I mean I can obviously some people
can hang in be social but yeah but it
did I just felt good
that's are you waking up with I was you
know just to wake up fresh head it day I
feel good it was nice yeah but he'll say
you know what you know it broke me was
Baltimore wasn't it
no I thought it was Baltimore you broke
no DC I was DC the gig the gig at the at
the W yeah yeah
didn't really break me but I was just
you know I didn't know you were drinking
that night but I drink later that night
he was that ha ha ok ok I had a couple I
don't want it to because you got scummy
in Baltimore
yeah Baltimore Watson WA got loose I
thought that's when you broke cuz you
got because you all of you went in
pretty hard
you were like Mortal Kombat you were
swaying man like this is mo [ __ ] broke
and went in hard you're gonna break make
it make it worth something
yeah I'm onna I always joke up on stage
about getting ripped but I do want to
get ripped I want to see what L do it'd
be great I think it's funny also to all
of it I mean obviously it's good for
help
and everything I'm standing up right now
cuz my legs it started cramping up yeah
that sucks but this heart it's hard to
go go rip from being bigger it's easier
to go rip if you're a skinny dude
already yeah then you just all you got
to do is crazy push up some pull-ups but
if you're a bigger guy that means you
got a diet first you got to cut all your
fat off yeah and then you got to go into
intense workouts and build your muscle
back up right you know that's what I
believe cuz I've always been kind of a
I've been a thicker guy my whole life
and there was a good portion of my life
where I worked out a ton but never could
quite get the rip I just get kind of
more like barely yeah but it's like
muscular but it's not rip muscular right
so you got a I think you got a shed the
fat first and then add the muscle so I
got it lose about 40 yeah ah my leg is
cramping up man ah ever sold to a man
that means you need to drink more water
leg cramp exclusive you know what it is
oh man that's cuz you need to drink more
water
ah oh oh alright
this is exclusive my my leg has never
I've done other people's podcasts many
times over the years and never caught a
leg cramp during any podcasts in the
past whatever how long I've done
people's podcasts eight years or
something and my second one of my own
I hit a crazy leg cramp out of nowhere
this sucks
let's just use this time to take a quick
commercial break
well I try to figure out my legs word
SeatGeek
is always the first place I go to look
for tickets to a game or concert that I
wasn't able to get into with the help of
one of my friends I got the seat geek
out on my phone and I used it to look up
how much my tickets get scalped for and
people are extremely ambitious and
hilarious but seeking is good does the
price comparison for you it has all the
different ticket size they put them in
one they make it easy it's smooth it's
an aggregator they get all of them and
see geek wants to help you get the most
bang for your buck that's why every
ticket on seat gig is given a grade
based on value you immediately see any
under priced seats and be able to find
the best deals that fits your budget
it's great for last-minute stuff say you
just look at you in a city sometimes I
go in a city and I'll pull up seat kicks
what's going on and seat geek syncs up
with your music on your phone and so
it'll show when your favorite artist is
play it's great see geek so get your $20
rebate on tickets download the free C
gig app go to the settings tab and click
add a promo code enter promo code Rambla
our AMPL er seat geek will send you $20
after you made your first ticket
purchase download the free seat geek app
and it's a promo code Rambler today our
AMPL e
gambler siegy how so you got on
headphones all got on headphones how so
your singing skills are the volume
levels the my my singing skills like
velvet I mean it might not be great but
you put some auto-tune on that [ __ ] we
used to do out on the show I think I
could throw some auto-tune on that do a
quick we bout to do quiz you questions
from the fans pick up the phone baby
pick
Oh
the phone it's time for is is hmm it's
time for questions all right so this one
the subject is life advice please
exclamation mark I don't know why would
you ask me for life advice but I'm open
to it
I have I'm 33 years old I've done
stand-up comedy since I was 19 years old
I would go on yeah but you have good
insight on stuff that's why either
you're a comic all right all right so
this one is by CEREC so sir it says dear
Hannibal I'm in college and my parents
are really against what I'm studying art
art yeah because they are both in the
medical field yeah
I'm actually doing much better than they
thought I would but they're still Sean
they're doubt every time I see them yeah
it makes going home and visiting family
a pain not only do they not believe in
me but they're super-conservative racist
sexist and etc I don't know what to do
because even if I do tell them they
don't listen help please
well you know what it sounds like you
need to take a nap and think about it
while you lay on your hilux personalized
mattress and also after you wake up from
the nap on that mattress that's
personalized to your body you should
pull out you should pull out your laptop
and watch some original series on Cecil
MVC's streaming network they have every
episode of Saturday Night Live and after
that after you slept on that helix
mattress and watched some content on
seeso you pull out your phone and open
up the seat geek app and see what events
I have it in it in town that you can go
to and get away from your parents
excellent advice
real slick okay next question
I don't know you know it's just they're
probably upset because they paying for
it if they're not paying for it
then it's really not their right to be
upset yeah you made that choice you want
to do art art is tough they can I think
this is worried but if you became a
successful artist didn't they'd say okay
we get it now but parents are gonna be
parents she said they're races and
everything yeah I don't know what to do
I mean yeah they just saw actually well
my parents aren't racist but they sound
a lot like my parents where they're just
kind of like typical agent archetype
where it's just kind of like that's not
practical
yeah you need to study law you need to
do something that's gonna guarantee you
some money for all this money you're
putting into school right
follow your heart right yeah you just
got to just block it out yeah listen to
uh listen to Eminem
I mean and all the time no I'm just
sweaty knees weak mom's sphaghetti mom
spaghetti put on some mom's spaghetti my
somebody made a version of that song
lose yourself yeah
where's this spaghetti just had his
mom's spaghetti mom's spaghetti
[Music]
[Music]
spaghetti mom spaghetti see how that
makes you feel on spaghetti and then go
to sleep on your hilux matches that good
but ya know parents sometimes you know
as the great will alert Smith once said
parents just don't understand yeah I
mean that is that maybe it's a
generational gap or whatever but
obviously you to you and your parents
don't see eye-to-eye so there's
something to go off there too
already just in general because you seem
like a pretty well-adjusted liberal
woman or you could boss up on them
what do you mean boss up on them say
next time they talking that [ __ ] you
there for the holidays you back home for
a weekend boss up yeah look them in the
eyes they start talking that [ __ ] say
hey mind dad such a [ __ ] ass up shut
the [ __ ] up tired of hearing this [ __ ]
about all right y'all oldest [ __ ] y'all
gonna be dead before me I'm your
daughter
I'm a mother I'm a boss shut up shut up
yeah I'd like animal furnace a lot shut
up yeah and other races are cool it's
all right to be here that's the advice
boss up on your parents boss the [ __ ]
have some weights this ways before do
some push-ups do some ketosis do 40
push-ups and then walk up in the house I
contact and bounce up on a [ __ ] asses
that's how I would do it a hundred
percent that's how I handle all the
conflicts in my life excellent advice
yeah all right let's move on to the next
one so this one is from Blair Blair and
it's titled he stole my vyvanse
and $40 and once
which is weirdly specific but anyways
she says hi
I need help deciding between two dudes
I've recently hooked up with the bus the
first one stole vyvanse from me and $40
in ones he's also a teen and has a
girlfriend I've been trying to avoid
thinking in platitudes such as boys are
stupid and girls have too high of
expectations so I'm willing to forgive
him guy number two and I hooked up in
his ex-girlfriend's bed don't ask and I
got a bench a bunch of boy why can't I
ask because I don't know we can't ask
now he's not lives yeah we email her
right so I got a snap off oh that's a
way that's way hard little group of
words to say I got a bunch of bedbug
bites a bunch of bedbug bites
wow that's pretty good you got some good
flow any I'm a rapper bunch of bedbug
bites and he hasn't called me back she
got in my bag got a bunch of bedbug
bites
I said you bout to get a bed bug in your
buzzing tonight you know that there's
got the bit but bites going through the
strike and I'm drinking on the sprite
with the bedbug bites it is tight babe
bug bites into the night and I buy our
own the booty and she says she won a
fight I said I fight in the bed bug
bites then we get it said at night and I
get it okay done and he hasn't called me
back in a month
so she got a bunch of bedbug bites and
calling back in a month he also hasn't
been outside a two-mile radius in the
past five years
who's the man for me or better yet who
should I go for next so one dude is
still in from her and the other one got
a bedbugs other ones stealing from her
and it's only 18 and has a girl for how
does she yeah I don't know how she is
she sounds like a mess to be honest yeah
but we all are at some point
I don't know I mean does she not have a
day to nap it seem like she needs a
branch yeah that's the first thing I
thought is she needs to just get on
tinder why you locked why you decided on
these two but she prints out a little
bit yeah cast out a bigger net what
garbage city do you live in Omaha oh
there's no wow yeah that the email
addresses from the University of Omaha
oh wow maybe it's one of Steve's friends
anyways I don't know I'm not deciding
between these does one do steals em feta
means and the other one got bedbugs
salary either
just move graduates you asking me
oh man this is no neither neither yeah
no sounds like yeah it's something yes
you need to you need to expand your
dating options if that's all you got
it's not a good place to be not a good
place to get the bed bug bites Finn
we're living it up for the night with
the bed bug buddies one fight I said not
a night with the bed bug bites at these
tight put all my surf for the night iron
it up while my body
hahaha I'm trying to bring in when I'm
rapping I'm trying to make my laugh into
something that rhymes like the laugh is
bars on his own
she was hahaha I grabbed a camera
hahaha like that whatever that's the end
of the advice segment well that's been
an that's the second episode of the
handsome ramble all right that's it
that's it we did it again episode 2 I
had a podcast this is easy I have it
have been doing this already actually
feel bad
I was I didn't feel bad but I felt a
little low-energy before we started yeah
it started building up we caught we
caught mom I just felt well I just felt
even but when we were talking before I
kind of felt just a little drained I
don't know one hungover but just kind of
tired yeah yeah well yeah you get a
little it's a little forced at first
because you're like oh [ __ ] I gotta talk
no I mean just in general it wasn't
about the net one I wanted to record it
wasn't about the being dreading the task
itself more about this how I felt right
before I was working I felt fine but I
just felt a little tired like I could
have used a Red Bull and now I feel
energized I got my float my flows back
I'm back in the pocket I'm back in the
pocket with my wraps coming through you
know I'm a snap yo I think this this
podcasts gonna be great for my rap
career yeah you know why cuz people
don't take my free styles from here yeah
they gonna strip the audio yeah and then
you gonna put them two beats and then
eventually eventually once the podcast
once the podcast grows it's gonna be so
many different free styles and some
people gonna just put it together and
then I'll have a mixtape without even
making my own mixtape don't it's gonna
be great man yep so check out tour dates
Hannibal Burres dot-com slash tour of
coming through DC coming through
Cincinnati say loose
Kentucky no not Kentucky
maybe Kentucky Kansas City Australia
Australia I can't do accents
I wish I could do is it too late to
learn how to access Australia that's not
it I'm bad at it you can take like boys
classes voice classes I don't want to
talk at it focus all right I get better
at DJ at first so subscribe share tweet
rap all of that stuff
the handsome Rambler it's Tony trim also
live life call your parents play video
games drink a lot of water eat fish boss
up on your parents if they talking that
[ __ ] and that's at Trump 2016
we are peace
[Music]
Ronna Glickman here from run and bevel a
to tell you this is your big chance to
see rana and beverly live with some of
your favorite podcasts also performing
comedy bang bang and Pia's pop-culture
happy hour spontaneous and with paul f
who we adore and war then now hear this
podcast Festival is October 28th to the
30th in sunny Anaheim California it's
gonna be absolutely fabulous see all
your favorite acts live go to now hear
this best dot-com to get you tickets
plus information on hotels and travel
when it's diff weekend
[Music]
this has been an ear wolf production
executive produced by Scott Aukerman and
Chris Bannon for more information and
content visit Earwolf calm
you